we're joined now and pleased to say by
emily thornberry of the labour party
thank you for being with us
keen obviously to talk about the local
elections but first we need to get your
reaction of course to the news from
durham police that they are going to be
investigating
the event that took place a campaigning
event that kirstarma was at to see
whether any covert 19 rules were broken
it's not a great look for labour reserve
well we'll answer whatever questions are
put to us and we'll do everything that
we can to help but we're completely
confident that no rules have been broken
so it's fine if they want to and i
appreciate they've been put under a lot
of pressure there's lots of people
who've been campaigning for the police
to er open this investigation lots of
conservative mps have been asking lots
of the conservative supporting
newspapers have been making a big fuss
about it if they're opening it again
that's fine we will answer questions um
kirsten has been very vocal when calling
for both boris johnson and rishi suno to
resign after they were found in breach
of the cover 19 rules if he's found in
breach of them he's going to have to go
isn't he let's look at it let's look at
what this is about you know what was
happening in number 10 was organized
breach
breaking of the rules it was done in
advance sue grey has talked about that
you know the fact that there was this
kind of let's think about this how can
we get round the rules what can we do
you know events that were not associated
with work um and that i think is a clear
breach you know of what is going on but
you know as i say we are confident that
there have not been any breaches the
rules as well i understand you're
confident there's nobody because it's
it's a different situation i'm not
making any comparison i'm just saying
that kirsten has called on well you are
more confident and risky to resign
because they found him breached the
rules
if he's been found and reached the rules
it would be untenable for him to stay on
yeah listen i'm approaching this being
completely confident that he hasn't
broken the rules so i mean there's
nothing pointing to you as well yeah but
there's no point in kind of commenting
on hypotheticals you know what the
police may or may not conclude you know
i'm confident that the rules haven't
been broken the police will come to that
that uh you know that conclusion that's
the end of it it's not an unreasonable
hypothetical when the police have
literally said they are reopening an
investigation into whether the wars were
broken yeah i mean i understand that but
i also understand that they've been put
under a great deal of pressure and we
are confident that the rules haven't
been broken so it really is the end of
the story
i'll just come in on that just um
kirsten was very clear in the comments
as what all of you yeah it must be clear
to the public that there can't be one
rule for one group of people and another
rule of course for everyone else of
course of course
but there's but there's not but i mean i
know of course and if there has been
a deliberate breaking of the rules you
know and coming into parliament and
lying about it then clearly but these
are not these are not comparable you
know kiera has not broken the rules the
prime minister has done consistently and
deliberately and lied about
his positions on cannibals he's not
going to get one
but he might he's been infested he's not
going to get one because he hasn't
broken the rules
um sorry i'm sorry to be boring about
this you know we are completely okay
you acknowledge that
that could become an issue given that
he's now under investigation
do you want to acknowledge that he
hasn't broken the rules because that's
what my position is is that he's not
broken the rules and you know and that's
that you know let's see what happens
next but we are completely confident
that he hasn't broken the rules and you
know this was this was investigated a
long time ago then conservative
newspapers conservative mps started
campaigning about it because of the
elections were coming up in order to try
to divert people the durham police been
put under pressure they've reopened the
investigation that's fine
kia will answer questions we will all
answer questions but we haven't broken
the investigation because they say
significant new evidence has come to
light you're saying it's purely
political they're saying they have new
evidence that has prompted them to
reopen cool if there's new evidence then
you know and then there's questions to
be answered you know we will answer the
questions and we will do everything that
we can to assess the police but we know
we've not broken the rules okay can i
ask a little bit about the way it's been
handled because if you take a step back
uh and i appreciate you know you you say
that you're confident no rules are
broken but just looking at the
communications around this it does feel
like there's been a bit of a drip feed
of information uh curry that we weren't
aware about and
journalists originally been told that
angelreina wasn't there and then being
told that oh no sorry that was a mistake
she was there yeah it was a mistake but
it was a mistake
yeah i mean i think i think what i would
do i mean from one hand like yeah i mean
that was a mistake right so i think what
happened was that was that journalists
did ask one of the press team and the
press team hadn't consulted and i'm
afraid made an assumption and and then
you know and said that angela wasn't
there three months go on go by nobody
asked us any other questions i mean it's
all there online it's not as though it
was being hidden you know that angela
was there um and then it comes up again
because the conservatives start
campaigning about it wouldn't it be
better but you know as soon as she was
asked sorry as soon as they were asked
they went yeah she was there you know
but there had been a mistake made by a
press officer and
you know and people aren't perfect okay
people make mistakes let's talk a bit
about the uh local elections uh now uh
shall we what do you make of the results
because it feels like there are some
bright spots for labor yeah but some
areas where perhaps you would have been
hoping to have done a bit better
i don't know if i agree with that i mean
listen i'm not saying that we haven't
got a huge amount of work to do but i
think that if you think about like the
morning after or the week after 2019
how bad it was how people were saying to
us it was pretty much the end of the
labour party we weren't ever going to
get back on our feet again this shows
that we have we have got back on our
feet again and and of the presentations
that we've had and the discussions that
we've had in the shadow cabinet this is
definitely at the top end of what we
were hoping was going to happen um and
you know and of course it we have we
still have a mountain to climb and we're
not pretending that we don't but if you
look at
you know the way in which we have you
know the results that we've had from
cumberland down to southampton to you
know to the to the suburbs of london to
the extraordinary results in central
london we're in play and and of course
we we still have to work in the next
couple of years but we're back and and
you know and there's and you know we're
on the right path to becoming the next
government on the path but yeah that's
you're not we're not there no no of
course not but i mean look how far we've
come for heaven's sake i mean look at
that because you know if you listen to
you know part of the people in the labor
party they have been you know saying
that jeremy corbyn was the complete low
point which you know if he's the worst
election result since 1935 you can see
why and yet you're now saying oh look
the 2018 local elections which he
thought were actually a high water mark
i mean shouldn't you be trying to be
doing a bit better than him no no no no
so
listen the results for example in london
were the worst for the conservatives
ever right in 2018.
it was a it was a terrible result for
them and we had done well
i'm just no no but i mean i'm like
you've asked me about this so i'm about
to acknowledge right worst results for
the conservatives ever you know best
results for labor for 50 years in london
and we've done even better you know so i
mean it's a patchy result but you know
that's kind of one thing to acknowledge
but what we need to be doing is we need
to be making sure that we get more seats
than the disaster of 2019. so the
question is where are we doing well so
we're doing well in cumberland there are
three marginal seats there there are two
marginal seats in southampton
if you look at where the where the swing
has happened and you were to move that
across the whole of that marginal seat
we would make another 13 14 seats now
that's not enough we're 80 seats behind
but it shows that we're on the right
road are you really uh hoping to be
honest to be able to ride on the back of
the liberal democrats a bit if they
manage to replicate this performance in
the south it could be them that oust the
conservatives for power really
i think that things have been extremely
unsettled over the last few years we
have never seen politics like this we
had a general election in 2019 that was
that was about brexit you know largely
about that and i think we've had parties
come and go we've had the brexit party
we've had ukip you know
the the voters are moving around
and we need to get into a settled
pattern and the next election will be
the general election where people will
need to make a decision
about which government they want what
national government they want and they
would they're looking and what we've
shown what we've seen overnight is that
they are fed up with this lot they are
fed up with this government with their
lies and and and so on now they haven't
yet and we haven't yet persuaded them
and last night wouldn't have been the
occasion to do it the next election has
to be the one in which we step up and we
get people's trust so
very quickly uh um if shinfane are the
largest parties should there be a
boulder pole in northern ireland what's
labour's position
our position is is that it has to be led
entirely by the good friday agreement
and it's not for us as a political party
to to try to change that agreement okay
just go on thank you very much emily
thornbury